let's say that you're curious about
studying the dimensions of the cars that
happen to sit in the parking lot and so
you measure their legs and so let's just
make the computation simple let's say
that there are spot there are five cars
in the pocket parking lot the entire
size of the population that we care
about is five and you go and measure
their lengths one car is four meters
long the other car another car is four
point two meters long another car is
five meters long the fourth car is four
point three meters long and then let's
say the fifth car is five point five
meters long so let's come up with some
parameters for this population so the
first one that you might want to figure
out is a is a measure of central
tendency and probably the most popular
one is the arithmetic mean so let's
calculate that first so we're going to
do that for the population so we're
going to use going to use mu so what is
the arithmetic mean here well we just
have to add all of these data points up
and divide by five and I'll just get the
calculator out just so it's a little bit
quicker and so this is going to be this
is going to be four plus four point two
plus five plus four point three plus
five point five and then I'm going to
take that sum and then divide by 5
divided by 5 and I get an error an
arithmetic mean for my population of
four point six of four point six so
that's fine and if we want to put some
units there it's four point six meters
now that's the central tendency or a
measure of central tendency we already
we also might be curious about kind of
what is how dispersed are the data is
the data especially from that central
tendency so what would we use well we
already have a tool at our disposal the
population variance and the population
variance is one of many ways of
measuring dispersion it has some very
neat properties which is
it tends the way we've defined it as the
mean of the squared distances from the
mean tends to be a useful way of doing
it so let's just do that let's let's
actually calculate the population the
population variance for this population
right over here
well well all we need to do is find the
distance from each of these points to
our mean to our mean right over here and
then take the meet and then square them
and then take the mean of those two
squared distances so let's do that so
it's going to be four minus four point
six squared plus four point two minus
four point six squared plus five minus
four point six squared plus four point
three minus four point six squared and
then finally losing running out of space
plus five point five minus four point
six squared and then we're going to
divide all of that I'm going to divide
all of that by five to get our
population variance and so what's that
going to give us let's get our
calculator out so four minus four point
six squared that's negative point six
squared negative point six squared is
going to be the exact same thing as
point six squared so let me write that
zero point six squared plus four point
two minus four point six is negative
four point six a negative point four but
when we square it the negative is going
to disappear so it's going to be plus
point four I'll just write point four
squared and then we have five minus four
point six that's 0.4 so plus 0.4 squared
four point three minus four point six
that's negative point three the negative
goes away when you scare it so it's
going to be plus 0.3 squared plus 0.3
squared and then finally five point five
minus four point six is going to be 0.9
so plus 0.9 squared
point nine squared and that and then we
will divide by the number of data points
we have
and we get 0.316 or if we want to write
it we could write Z this is going to be
0.316
now let me ask you what is a mildly
interesting question what would be the
unit's what would be the units for this
population variance we since we're
carrying we're happening happen to care
about units in this video well up here
this is 4 meters minus 4.6 meters 4.2
meters minus 4.6 meters so these are all
meters these are measurements in meters
we saw it up here so these are all
measurements and meters when you
subtract them you will get meters but
when you square them you get meters
squared plus meters squared plus meters
squared plus meters squared plus meter
squared and then you're just dividing
that by a eunice a unitless count of the
number of data points you have
so the units here are going to be square
meters and so you might say hey that's
kind of a weird unit if we're trying to
figure out if we're trying to visualize
or think about how dispersed we are from
the mean if we if when I visualize it I
visualize dispersion or how varied they
are in terms of meters not meters
squared so what could we do and the big
hint is comes out of just even the
notation for variance it's this Sigma
symbol squared so why don't we just take
the square root of it so why don't we
just take why don't we just take the
square root of our variance which we
will denote with just a sigma makes a
lot of sense and in this case what's it
going to be it's going to be the square
root of 0.316
and then what are the unit's going to be
it's going to be just meters and we end
up with so let me take the square root
of 0.316 and I get zero point five six
I'll just round to the nearest
thousandth zero point five six - so it's
approximately zero point five six two
meters so you might be saying Sal what
do we call this thing that we just did
the square root of the variance and here
we're dealing with the population where
you haven't thought about sampling yet
the square root of the population
variance what do we call this thing
right over here and this is a very
familiar term often times when you take
an exam this is calculated for the
scores on the exam this is our
population we just in a new color I'm
using that yellow a little bit too much
this is the population population
standard standard deviation it is a
measure of how much the the the data is
varying from the mean in general the
larger this value that means that the
data is more varied from the population
mean the smaller it's less varied and
these are all somewhat arbitrary these
are all somewhat arbitrary definitions
of how we've defined variance we could
have taken things to the fourth power we
could have done other things we could
have taken not taking them to a power
but taking the absolute value here the
reason why we do it this way is it has
neat statistical properties as we try to
build on it but that's the population
standard deviation which gives us nice
units meters meters in the next video
we'll think about the sample standard
deviation